have you ever committed a crime I'm
considering one now we get it dizzy
channel you guys have a reputation to
protect you don't want any of your
actors getting into legal trouble which
makes sense since you tend to work with
minors but would it kill you guys to
ease up a little bit we mean you're
stripping your stars of their
individuality
and learning to be yourself from a young
age is kind of a big deal we were
shocked by some of the rules you ask
your stars to follow it's no secret that
being a Disney Channel star isn't all
that in a bag of chips but hey it does
help aspiring actors become big-time
celebrities but some of Disney's rules
are so restrictive it makes us wonder if
the price of Fame is too expensive watch
until the end to find out why a Disney
Channel stars contract never expires
even after they pass away speak like
this not like that it's common for
Disney Channel stars to get a little
rambunctious once their contracts come
to an end and well we can't say we
really blame them while it's hard to
believe Disney Channel executives
instruct their stars on how to speak in
Bella Thorne's case she was told to
speak in a higher pitch because her
naturally husky voice allegedly came off
as a bad girl vibe but after a hot
minute
Bella chose to speak in her natural tone
no matter the consequence don't
negotiate when you work for the House of
mouse you don't get to call the shots
and when it comes to salary there isn't
much room for negotiation Miley Cyrus
had to find this out the hard way
believe it or not but Miley was once the
lowest paid actor on her very own show
but of course she didn't know this when
she signed on no matter how successful a
Disney Channel TV series becomes the
cast salary tends to remain the same no
ifs ands or buts don't skip school it
makes total sense that the Disney
Channel doesn't want it starts to set a
bad example so skipping school just
isn't
option but we're not talking about high
school we're talking about the house of
Mouse's very own classes Disney Channel
stars are required to take classes on
social media and scandal management
refusing to take these classes can lead
to a stars contract being terminated you
break it you pay for it to say that the
Disney Channel racks in a lot of dough
would be an understatement so naturally
you would think that stars wouldn't have
to walk on eggshells while on said but
that's just not the case if a star
accidentally breaks or damages a prop it
comes out of their paycheck back in the
day a handful of stars had to pay up to
five hundred dollars because they
damaged their set of mouse eared hats
learn how to play dumb it doesn't matter
how smart a person is when they work for
the Disney Channel they have to learn
how to play dumb on top of acting extra
bubbly during interviews stars are
quizzed and schooled on how to avoid
answering off-limit questions during
interviews the Jonas Brothers were
instructed on how to play dumb on more
than one occasion Joe Jonas was even
told to start talking about his adorable
dog if the going got rough no sick days
Miley Cyrus spent the majority of her
teenage years filming Hannah Montana and
it came at a cost
one day when Miley was wearing white
pants she got her first ever period
while filming the show most girls take
the day off when something like this
happens but Disney Channel executives
wouldn't let Miley go home taking a sick
day just wasn't an option no matter how
embarrassed and distraught their young
star was keep your lyrics pg-13 just
like Bella Thorne and Miley Cyrus the
Jonas Brothers had their fair share of
run-ins with the Disney executives the
Jonas Brothers are known for writing
their own lyrics and putting on a show
but when they were signed on with the
house of mouse their lyrics fell under
scrutiny any lyrics that were deemed too
risky had to be taken out of the song
which made writing authentic music all
the
more challenging hide your body the
Disney Channel mostly works with
children and the last thing they want is
for them to look too mature so on the
off chance that an actress starts to
develop too early Disney Channel
executives immediately step in some
girls are made to wear tight shirts
under their sweaters in hopes of looking
younger and more innocent what I forgot
to mention is that I'm completely
reinventing myself while this rule has
become a little less strict over the
last decade or so
Disney still has to say over their stars
wardrobes ask for permission asking for
permission is something that most minors
are used to but bella thorne still had
some issues with this role while most
teenagers can post everything on social
media Disney stars have to get the green
light before posting just about anything
sella received their shock of a lifetime
when she was scolded for posting a
picture in a bikini that her mother had
gifted her it's never over most stars
refused to use their authentic names
because once they signed the contract
Disney owns the rights to their
on-screen names amongst many other
things but unlike most contract Disney
Channel contracts don't end when the
signee passes away in fact the Disney
Channel takes out lofty insurance deals
on their biggest stars so while it's
totally despicable the company benefits
greatly whenever a tragedy strikes which
one of these rules surprised view the
most sound off in the comments thanks
for watching hit that subscribe button
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up we'll see you next time
on the things
[Music]